Hi, everyone. In this video, we're going to go and take a look at the course outlined
for this series of videos. And we're going to also take a look at lighting terminology
and types. So let's get started. So lighting terminology and types is one of the first
topics we'll cover today. We'll look at lighting definitions and types static
versus dynamic and light types in general. From there, we'll go ahead and take a look
at lighting property settings. And we'll dive into lights a lot deeper. We'll look
at lighting properties and light mobility when it comes to workflows. From there, we're
going to take a look at an introduction to Lumen. We'll look at what is Lumen, how
to set it up, quality control, tips and tricks, and Lumen visualization mode. From
there, we're going to take a look at Nanite and virtual shadow maps, why use Nanite,
using it, virtual shadow maps, overview, mesh distance, field edits, and visualizers.
From there, we'll go ahead and take a look at lighting tools, environment light mixer,
light mixer, and the day sequence tool. Now this is going to be a brief overview
on some of these, because we dive into such things such as the day sequence a lot
deeper in other courses. And finally, we'll look at interactive lighting exercise, we're
going to go and light a hero object. And we're going to do it interactively. And I'll
walk you through some of the things to keep in mind when doing so. So let's go
ahead and jump right in. So lighting terminology and types. So lighting
definition types when it comes to working in our real time environment
fall under these three main categories that we'll be adjusting and tweaking to
get the visuals the way that we want. We'll look at direct lighting, indirect
lighting, bounce lighting, and shadows. In any DCC, you should be able to get
your direct lighting where you want it. And ones that are a bit more realistic
and not a light on the workflows, you're going to be able to do GI. And that
is the bounce lighting. Unreal is one of the key and one of the forefront
tools in creating realism. And it does a spectacular job of creating GI,
global illumination in your scenes and bounce light. Now shadows in Unreal
previously were big shadows in which you would work with shadow maps. But
now you can actually work with virtual shadow maps. Now, the difference between
them is shadow maps were for the baking scenario. And virtual shadow
maps allow us to update our shadows on the fly. The shadows were baked
previously, where you would use our renderer, which we'll talk about in
just a second, called light mass. But now we can use lumen and lumen and
virtual shadow maps work fantastic together.
So speaking of, lumen is Unreal 5's fully dynamic global illumination and
reflection system that is designed for next generation consoles, but can
also be used for linear productions such as film and ICV effects. It is
the default global illumination reflection system. Before that it was
default baked, but now lumen is the one that starts and is up and ready
to go in which you just have to change a few things to get even more
visual fidelity. Lumen renders diffuse interflexion with infinite
bounces and indirect specular reflections in large detailed
environments at scales ranging from millimeters to kilometers. Now the
big scenario is used quite often for architecture and is you can
think of it as a renderer such as with V-Ray and Corona, but you're
typically just rendering your lights and we use our light mass
radiosity for that. Now that's an older tool, but it still can be
used in Unreal and is used quite often for architectural
demonstrations and so forth because they just need a static
environment. But lumen is a good option outside of that because it
works so great and allows you to update your lighting on the fly
without having to do a remake. Now you can use ray tracing too,
with lumen, which helps support its quality control and allows you
to get some really great results. You don't have to if your
system doesn't support it, but that option is there, which is
really great in our project settings. It just gives you
better visual fidelity, better performance, and allows you to
update things overall and allows your GPU to really go in
there and make it so that you can build quickly, light
quickly, and get realism as quick as possible. You'll see
there's a note on the bottom, some aspects of ray
tracing is taken into account with Lumen such as reflections
and some light and object relationships to help
performance. But higher quality settings in the GPU can be GPU
expensive. You'll hear me mention this a couple times, just
things to consider when we dive into the Lumen settings is
cool as it is. And as we bump things up, just like
anything, as you bump up the quality, your GPU may take a
little bit of a hit. So please consider what you have and
what you're working with hardware wise. Here's some of the
light tools that we have are light types. We have a
directional light. This is primarily used for sunlight, we
have the point light. In cases of on 3d city max, you can
think of it as omni light, we have the spotlight, we have
the rec light. And the rec light is one of my favorite
lights to use. It's great for fill lights and even rim
lighting setting up. It is one of the more expensive ones
and I'll reiterate some of these later. Because it's like
a series of point lights in a rectangular space. We have
skylight that allows us to use an HDRI image based ambient
light, it'll either pluck it from your scene or you can
load an HDR image in there. And again, I'll walk you
through how those work. A lot of times our product, people
are using Unreal to advertise a product such as a car or
phone, we'll choose that and not much else because it's
simple and gets straight to the point. We have HDR
backdrop. It is a predefined HDR lighting blueprint setup.
This can be used in games like in behind a window, obviously
interactively, you wouldn't necessarily have that in there
because it looks really fake. But it's great for a nice
filler. If you need something for say a backdrop for a car,
or some sort of product or architectural thing you're
working with. And in a game, you can put it behind a
window. So you can use a little smoke and mirrors to
hide that from your audience. Sun in sky lighting blueprint
setup. So this also is available. This allows you to
punch in the time of day, and longitude and latitude. Now
the only things you need to keep in mind working with
this, some people may choose the new day sequence, which
we'll mention later, which works similar to it, but not
quite, it allows you to have the time of day change
the change of the time of day any way that you want,
and even automatically have it so that it has the sunset and
sunrise. So that's actually pretty cool. And we'll dive
into that briefly, we get into that a little bit
heavier with our atmospheric lighting. So we will be
mentioning some of these tools for the most part. These
primary ones in pink are the ones we'll be focusing on.
That's it with this lesson. You'll see here a link where
you can dive in a bit deeper to know more about
lights. In the next lesson, we're going to go and take a
look at lighting properties. Thanks again.